you play of course in the movie
Chappaquiddick you play which is about
the the tragedy of Senator Ted Kennedy
at the time going off of a bridge and
he's with a young woman who had worked
within Robert Kennedy staff and she's
she's drowned and Mary Jo Kopechne Oh
Mary Jo Kopechne II and this was you
know huge story worldwide and I remember
it even as a little kid
this being massive story of course in
Massachusetts where he was a senator you
play a real guy named Joe Gargan mm-hmm
in this and and he's got a fascinating
relationship with Ted Kennedy because
he's a cousin he's sort of supposed to
help the senator get away with or
facilitate him in anything he needs to
do so there's a lot of loyalty there but
you're conflicted because you also know
sometimes this line gets crossed fair I
love it I have nothing to add
yeah that was perfect I know that you're
a recent dad so I thought I would do the
interview for you yes I'm glue
completely spaced out but yes my so dad
let me tell you how we made the movie
basically I showed up I got a perm and
and yeah the story is incredible and a
lot of people have kind of forgotten
this chapter of the Kennedy story and I
think it's just a really powerful thing
to to tell especially even as someone I
was raised as a Kennedy supporter as
someone who kind of venerates that name
but but our heroes are complicated and
sometimes awful yeah and and it's
important to just accept the whole truth
I guess you play it was interesting
because your character Joe Gargan is a
big Red Sox fan and the year is 1969 and
yes so you're really into the Red Sox
and I was wondering you're very
convincing but I was thinking is it
helps a sports for not I'm not I'm not
and I can that was one of the things
about the character Ike you're a drug
you are a good act thank you very much
yeah alright but that was one of the
things that I had to work hard to
achieve was a sort of fake passion for
sports because I don't care at all about
sport much don't yeah they're angry that
they exist no but I just can't walk up
to everyone's always talking about
sports I'm actually jealous of the the
bonding and camaraderie that people have
but I just can't even speak the language
I'm like you so hi guys the the who had
the greater point tally between the
teams last night yeah it's not really it
doesn't it doesn't work it does that I
don't get I don't get invited to that
are equally under you could then bond or
yes there's so Zach Galifianakis and I
have a running joke because we both hate
sports one thing to just not be
interested but to adamantly hate them oh
and rüdiger idea of sports that's very
strange
yeah no Zach was a queer a running joke
where he'd come up and say oh and you're
from Atlanta your big Falcons fan oh
yeah love the Falcons well how'd they do
this weekend and I say oh is it is it
hockey season already just over and over
again is trying to play along but
getting it wrong every time every time
you